[Music]
so hello everyone
so it's my great pleasure to introduce
joseph urban who he's been
working on using machine learning
for formalized mathematics so many of
you have probably heard
that machine learning has been making
some
big strides in that direction but i
should say that joseph
is not working on this only on in during
past five years or ten years but maybe
nearly 20 years if i'm not mistaken
so uh so really he has experience
in this field quite extend and
he just last year just a few months ago
he finished he's completed
successfully his erc grant on this talk
on this topic sorry and uh so he will
tell us more about this
and uh on on and um
yeah what else should i say oh yeah i
should mention that
he's also worked on on big formalization
projects
so he participated in the kepler's
conjecture formalization
and the miser libraries and and
i'm sure he will mention this
more carefully um than i do so uh joseph
it's your floor
thanks mikalash and thanks to joe
and all the organizers for this
opportunity
to talk to two mathematicians of this
this great anniversary of the portuguese
mathematical society so
so the title of the talk is developments
in
artificial intelligence and fear empty
ring and
as mikash mentioned i i have a long
history
going like almost 25 years back when i
basically decided
to uh instead of doing mathematics to
to to use computers to do mathematics
because it was sort of the time
when ibm ibm's deep blue
uh managed to to beat kasparov and
bibles so that i'm a church as player
and i i was thinking well if we can do
it in chess
what what are the obstacles preventing
us to to do it
in mathematics and in science in in
general
so so this is this is
a bit of an overview talk about
basically where we are today uh
so the the the very high level
motivation
for this work is what i just said is to
basically try to automate mathematical
and scientific thinking
and when you sort of go into this meta
mode
and try to analyze uh what it is and
obviously i'm not the first one like
there are people like
puanka and turing and even leibniz
who studied this quite a lot
then one thing you
realize quite quickly is that a lot of
mathematics
is not just formal sort of deductive
reasoning
but but it's a lot of uh
more of inductive or abductive
reasoning when you are using analogies
you are detecting patterns in your
reasoning
and you are sort of learning from
both your successes and failures and
that there are all these feedback loops
when
you are trying to prove
something and you initially fail
and then you sort of try to see
what what is wrong why why does it work
on a smaller example and that doesn't
work
in in the sort of more general case
and uh so so what what i basically
decided to do
as the sort of first step which uh so
far has taken
over 20 years and it's still not
finished
is to look for some sort of
approximation
of something like uh
we do like when we are for example
learning from textbooks and
solving some exercises and becoming
better and better
doing more and more complicated theorems
so
so the approximation to the textbooks
that
that are that i found are
large libraries of formal mathematics of
formal theories definitions
theorems and proofs and basically
i'm i'm trying to to do
to to make the machines uh prove
as many of of these theorems and
some of them are pretty hard uh as
possible
and uh that that's basically the whole
setting where uh where we work so so we
sort of
typically drew something cooler and from
it and
prove to something more thanks to the
learning and then
look at the capability of our learning
systems
and try to improve them by making them
generalize better etc etc
absolutely so so why
would you do such a thing apart from the
sort of
very aish and curiosity driven
motivation today and why would anybody
fund
such an effort so it turns out that
automated reasoning and automated tier
entry ring
is actually useful today and
it's it's useful it's interestingly
useful
also for mathematics so thanks to
for example the development of computer
algebra systems
uh and computers in general
we and you as mathematicians probably
know this quite a bit uh we
we are creating proofs
that our computer assistant they are big
and they are hard to verify so so there
are these proofs
uh like the truth of the catholic
conjecture
or the proof of the order or phi
thompson theorem
that are relatively big and for example
in the case of kepler-conducture
mathematicians that their viewers really
struggled to uh to completely
make sure that the proof is correct that
the the proof
is bug-free so so so that's one use of
like basically automated improving
interactivity or improving formal
verification
the the sort of more industrial use is
that
today companies like for example
intel amazon microsoft
are funding projects um
or even like darpa uh are funding
projects to to verify
various parts of hardware and software
so today we we really have like for
example
verified hardware architectures like
floating point
arithmetics and processors we have
verified compilers
we have verified operating system
microkernels
etc etc so people even have companies
that verify
like trading rules uh for
for banks because this is apparently
becoming an issue or
transport systems and the the
technologies
like the sort of most um
expressive formalism which is typically
some first order higher logic
theory type theory for for doing these
things
is sort of exactly the same technology
as as the formalism for uh verifying
like these complicated mathematical uh
conjectures or
tools uh so so the field
is sort of going hand in hand uh driven
both
by the sort of fancy mathematical
projects and
the the industrial applications of
uh of these technologies and the the big
issue
with this is that um
the technology is um currently quite
hard to use
and it's exactly because it's it's not
very smart
so when a mathematician says something
uh like this is easy this is trivial
uh you do it by using x or y
the the systems that we currently have
are
are not yet at that level they so they
require
that the people who want to construct
the formal proof to do
to do much more work and because of that
it's tedious and for example only a few
mathematicians
would sort of do that rather than sort
of flying high
in their sort of high temperature modes
where they are
producing a lot of conjectures and
quickly refuting them etc
so so like the the formal through the
computer verified proof
has really a lot of benefits like you
can really
collaborate with the computer in amazing
ways
but currently there is this barrier
which sort of prevents it
for most mathematicians and
like that there are these blue sky ai
visions that are so sort of
alluded to uh so
we or many of us believe that
mathematics and hard sciences are
sort of the pinnacle of human
intelligence
and if somebody claims that they can
develop
strong ai ai well then
they should be able to to do mathematics
at least on the human level
and despite all the ai hype that has
been happening
in the last let's say five six years uh
we are the ai systems are actually not
very good today at
doing doing math at the level uh
which at which mathematicians are doing
it
so so this is this is definitely
uh a very uh
very interesting objective and if we
manage at least a bit
to to automate parts of math and science
well then like the sky is the limit
right like we could
do like automatic physics for example
right like you we could really do
automated mathematicians and automated
sciences
and like there has been plenty of dreams
also on the slide i have leibniz and
john mccarthy and you can you can look
at these these things if you are
interested
oh what is formal mathematics so i will
not do too much on this because of the
limited time
so basically like it's it's interesting
some some mathematicians
know this some mathematicians sort of
delegate this stuff to
logicians so thanks to
this program of let's say
leibniz and then going to frag russell
hilbert and i don't know ghetto turing
uh
what happened in the beginning of the
last century
is is that mathematics was sort of
embedded in logic in um
and then that that's really i think that
some mathematicians don't even perceive
yet like like it's
sort of a creepy revolution
that you may or may not acknowledge or
you may even sort of resist it and
be a counter revolutionary uh
but but to a large extent like these
this vision
have started to be realized uh because
by the way like like this sort of
symbolistic program
led to to the rise of computers like by
people like turing and church and
fundaments etc and they
like in the 50s and 60s people really
took this seriously and started to
play with the idea of implementing
symbolic logic
on on computers and like formal
mathematics on computers
so they they started to create systems
like automatic lcf
misar and q7 acl2
hol isabel so these are all
system created by these people like
melbourne etc
which you can use to state
formally your axioms and your theorems
in and in a way that the computer
parses them understands them so it's a
bit like a programming language
you you also state your inference rule
and in the same way
and then then you write your two as sort
of sequences of the
like inferences right so so you you you
then
use the computer to check that the proof
is really
going from your axioms to to your
conjecture and each inference
is sort of correct according to your
specification
so so it sounds like a very simple idea
uh the the issue with that and the the
main research topic in
in let's say the formal mathematics or
interactive improvement field over the
last
i don't know 60 years is how to actually
make it work for mathematicians
because um as i said the the
mathematicians typically very
on a much higher level
than these detailed
atomic inference rules and and you need
something in between
and people have been creating for
example more and more complicated
proving procedure
like sometimes called tactics and in
some of the systems
or that they have been programming
complicated
algorithms to capture the notion of
obviousness like
what is it to be an obvious inference
uh but but still like despite the years
of research
like i said it's still not doing
what you mean quite often uh
but but on the other hand i would say
that thanks to these
very big projects that happened recently
like the form of peripheral
conjecture or of the other theorem
the these things are really changing and
more and more mathematicians
are sort of coming uh
to experiment with these tools and the
tools are getting better and better
to some extent also thanks to the sort
of ai
um ai part ai
the intelligence that we are trying to
put into the systems
here is a quick example small example
by my colleague from the netherlands
fake video
about the irrationality of square root
of two
so he always shows this small proof from
hardy and right
which shows i don't know in
six steps by contradiction that the
square root of two is rational
and i guess each of you has seen this do
so so i will not
go through it here and and this is
interesting this is exactly the same
text written formally
in a proof system called mizar
where you have keywords like crm
to assume consider thus
contradiction and and and this
is something that really compiles in in
the system so so the system will
basically manage to read this sort of
programming language
and it will tell you that that there are
no
syntactic errors there are not even
any like high level natural deduction so
if you
sort of manage to justify each of these
steps
then the whole proof is really a proof
of the goal that you are proving
and and what would i sort of omit it
from from this
through sketch are under exact
justifications of the steps
which would be typically by referring
to to some previous um theorem or
definition
in the library uh this
is the proof of the same thing
in a system called whole light which is
a very different system what's called a
tactical tactical system so so in that
system
you take the goal and you gradually
modify and decompose it using tactics
so for example the first thing is some
simplification tactic using
um some some definitions typically so
what does it mean to be rational etc etc
and then you can do some rewriting some
discharging
etc etc uh so so this is
this is a very powerful um methods
of interactive you're improving the
the systems like whole light are
programmable
and they allow you to sort of build up
stronger and stronger targeted
automation for your theories
so unlike the previous example
where let's say there would typically be
just
one method how to justify everything
let's say some
weak ish first order automated theorem
here you can if you if you are into it
if you are
if you and if you need it you can really
for example program
complicated decision procedures in in
these systems
uh i think this is the last example so
that's a system called isabel hall
and it's an interesting combination of
the two approaches so
so the proof is declarative or mostly
recorded if like
in in the example but it also
allows you to to use more
complicated tactics for discharging your
goals so for example you can say
buy auto sim etc etc which is
some basically simplification
procedure inside isabel that you can
further tweak by giving it
various arguments a big example of
formal mathematics
is this fly spec project uh which is the
formal proof of the tablet conjecture
uh so the capital conjecture is a
conjecture by
kepler which was stated in 1611 in
prague by kepler
uh about the most compact way of
stacking balls
of the same size in space and
uh he claimed that it's this sort of
pyramid but there are also equivalent
packings that give you the same density
and the conjecture was open
until i think 1998 when
american mathematician tom hales was
this
student proved it using a lot of
computation and as i said the
mathematicians
had a hard time to to review that proof
so
tom decided to to do the proof formally
mostly in the whole light system also a
bit in the isabel system
and it took about 20 to 30 person years
and in 2014 the proof
was finished so so now thanks to the
formal proof technology we
basically know that the catholic
conjecture
is no longer a conjecture but by the
theorem
but it's a really big formal project
with over 20 000 dilemmas
in all parts of mathematics many parts
of mathematics
and like here is an example
of the statements of the lemmas that you
are proving there so so
written in the whole light language so
you say
if s is a polyhedron and c is
a face of s then c is also a polyhedron
so so we have
20 000 lemons like magnets
i'll i'll also tell you a bit
about automated theorem previous so so
these
this is like a different part of the
automated reasoning field
where people are really trying to
design programs that will do all the
work for you so you
you just state some axioms and a
conjecture
and you will you will hope that the
system
will find the proof automatically for
you
this is one of the oldest ai fields like
it
comes from 1950s from people like martin
davis et cetera
and there are many systems today like
vampire
etc etc uh they
sort of combine various sort of
logically based um by you could say
a bit brute force style or
complete calculi but sort of guarantee
that
if there is a preview you will not omit
the proof that you will somehow
not miss the proof and they use
like various procedures like the the
best known ones resolution
superposition is a big one tableau
snp is so sort of a newer thing where
things are also combined with
targeted decision procedures etc etc
and typically people equip these
automated syrian previous
with some sort of human programmed human
design heuristics that
intelligently prune the search space
but if you like what i did some some
would say
15 20 years ago try to use these systems
to
to prove uh facts like
let's say this this fact
in in the sort of fly spec project
using some let's say 10 000 lemons
then then these systems would sort of
quickly
explode on you because they they
typically
they're not designed for dealing with
huge corpora of let's say
mathematical knowledge uh so
so so what what i have been trying to do
quite a bit
is to basically learn from
many proofs in that are already
available in this sort of
formally written textbooks how to
how to select the right knowledge
from the big textbooks and how to how to
guide
the the current proof using some sort of
generalization
of the knowledge that has been already
used
previously and obviously that's also
combined with some
certainty for a search so i will show
you some examples later
and like there is quite a bit of history
also
to this like to two combinations of
artificial intelligence and fear
improving
so you can you can go back to poincare
and
hilbert uh and lanzai gilbert's dream
to to automate mathematics and the
sort of heart undecidability results by
turing and church and then
turing is interesting because he
basically
in his later work argues that machines
actually
can learn anything that
uh intelligent humans can do so he sort
of contradicts the
later naysayers like for example
pandoras who would say that
the ghetto theorem is some sort of
barrier for
machines to to do advanced mathematics
and then later in like 70s 80s
that is very by pat langley and that
clan out
on for example symbolic systems that
invent
the kepler laws or automated
mathematician by the clinic which
sort of produces concepts and
conjectures in some sort of symbolic
heuristically guided way
and then in in the 90s uh people started
to combine machine learning
uh with automated trm previous so so
that's
uh mostly very of a group in munich by
stefan schultz and singer and others
and as i said like my
my master thesis is some 20 25 years ago
when i was trying to basically learn
explainable
rules from from this big mathematical
corpora by a technique called
inductively programming which is some
sort of explainable
generalization process and i would say
that since
let's say 2000 uh what we have been
gradually doing more and more and the
community has been growing especially in
the last five years
is to really use a large
formal mathematical corpora to
to sort of develop combined
methods that sort of both do
the sort of deductive improving and
learn some sort of knowledge from this
corporate
that would in turn uh sort of guide
the the deductive systems so so it leads
to many of these
feedback soups and for
for people who have learned about deep
learning
and ai i suggest this talk of vanguard
soul which
is i think eight years ago in 2018
three years ago where he also explains
the the sort of variety of the ai
methods so
even though deep learning is really cool
and it gave us
a lot recently that there are
really many other ai approaches
and i i guess nobody really believes
that
deep learning is is the only
thing that will make a
superhuman ai like it seems that
basically we will need a spectrum of ai
methods to
to and that's what also my research is
showing
so so a bit about what we are
doing in practice or in more detail
so you can divide things
into various levels on which
you are using the ai or the sort of
machine learning
to to guide the crm improving processes
so on on the very high level it's this
task when you have a big corpus big
textbook
and you have a new conjecture and if you
if you give the whole
corpus which may have twenty thousand
one hundred thousand dilemmas in it
to today's automated year employer
then it will basically immediately
explode
and do very little or almost nothing
uh so so the way how you can
very significantly improve the
performance of such systems
is by pre-selecting the right knowledge
from these big corporations these big
textbooks
so that's called premise selection and a
lot of work has been done
on the topic you can you can also
do basically machine learning for
selecting
good cr improving strategies or
portfolios
or strategies for problems and that
means that you need to characterize the
problem somehow
and then you need to do the machine
learning on like which problems are
solved by the strategies
and you could even combine it with some
automated invention
of new strategies for example if you
have some language
for defining the programs or the
strategies
you can also reselect uh
hints um which is basically
a related lemons uh
foreign for steer improving and that
that's a sort of a specific
method which is used today
for one of the most mathematical
things done with automated theorem
previews which is
the um research on
loops and quasi groups by bob vera and
michael kenyon
predominantly using river9 and
that's that's a i'll i'll say about it
a bit more later but that's that's
really
uh a very um
advanced area where these people can
produce very long crews like 20 000 to
100 000
inferences long tubes and uh
they really solve open conjectures so
actually this week
uh michael kenyon and bob would have
advanced a breakthrough in
solving um well not completely solving
but a major milestone in
uh in the end conjecture in the a
billion in a mappings
uh conjecture uh and and they they got
it by using this technology
so so it's it's one really exciting and
practical use of ultimate theorem
proving
guided by by these uh previously created
lemons
you can go low level so you can sort of
guide every inference types of the
automated theorem three waves
you can go mid level so you can take
these interactive sharing previews
and guide the application of tactics
which is typically
some bigger block like some bigger
algorithm
and then you you can do all sorts of
other things so you can invent suitable
conjectures suitable concepts you can
try to explore stronger
theories you can obviously do all these
feedback loops between crew income
learning
and a very interesting relatively recent
task we've been doing it for some six
years now
is auto formalization so so you can
take a piece of latex and try to train
something like google translate to
translate it
into formal language that you can then
proof check so so that
seems especially today quite quite
doable
it's not totally impossible i'll show
you some examples
data sets well there's quite a few of
these of these libraries and
i will i will not go too much into them
in this stock
demos i i have some more time so i will
show you at least some of them um
so last year we started to do a big
evaluation on the visa library
so so here is one example when we proved
the pythagoras theorem for inner
product spaces so
maybe a bit of context what we started
to do last year
is to um is to take the full mizar
library which is something like
60 000 top-level programs
and and we are running the learning
proven group of them so initially
we have an untrained crm period which
can prove let's say 15 000 of these
programs
then we train some machine learning
guidance on
on these groups and then we plug the
machine learning guidance into the
automated theorem program and it's
called
ether and the guiding system is called
enigma
and by doing that the guided hearing
improver is smarter and it gives small
previews
and you can you can do many iterations
of this procedure
giving you more and more tools so by
let's say june 2020
uh we got something like 38 000 plus
and the current uh
the current state is that we have about
percent of the missile library uh
drift automatically so so that's quite
a nice progress and
as part of doing this let me
try to do this pythagorean
thing um
we at some point used this theorem
which uh you can you can see
self-written formally
and uh linked uh
and it sort of shows you how the plugs
are done in the media system
so so you have some sort of inner
product space
and two points in it which are
orthogonal and then you basically say
that the norm squared of x plus y is the
norm
of x squared plus the norm of y squared
and the way you prove it is that you
sort of assume that x and y are
orthogonal
then from that you conclude that the
scalar product is zero by using the
definition
of orthogonality and then you follow all
these lemmas
and then you sort of start expanding the
the various definitions and using
various theorems to to conclude that it
actually holds
and uh click back
so so this proof takes
181 steps of inference steps basically
of the automated tiering preview of the
e3
we needed well initially the the pilgrim
was given
something like 342
axioms which are selected from the big
mesa library which is something like 100
facts uh in it and
uh the the search
took something like 30 seconds it it
generated
something like 65 000 facts
while doing this and
one hundred of them were selected
by the sort of ai in
in the theorem preview as the good ones
which will likely lead us to to the
truth and
as the theorem preview is generating
this new and new facts
the the trained machine learner
trained on on the previous cruise is for
for
each newly generated fact telling us
whether this fact is likely to
contribute to the proof or not
and we are sort of ranking the facts
according to to their usefulness
and doing the inferences with the sort
of most
likely facts so so in the end
this leads us to uh
to this proof which consists of of these
facts that are actually needed like
these are the steps in the in the proof
and these steps come from
34 axioms so if you if you are really
interested you can click
on on on the ether2 which looks
horribly it's it's something like this
but it
ends ends with you basically so
so that's sort of one sort of complete
example of
what we are doing uh
i i could show you a bit more but but
i'm
a bit out of time so maybe i'll
i'll just show you the last one which is
a bit different
on a bit different topic so
so so this is the auto formalization
demo
and it basically shows you how we
try to turn something reasonably
informally written like
um in the idol this would be a latex
how we try to use some sort of
trained machine learning parser to
turn it into formal
expressions in in this case in the whole
light language
and uh what we are doing on top
of this sort of probabilistic parsing
is that we are as as we are doing the
parsing we are type checking
the formal expressions that are coming
out of the parser
and we are trying also to prove them or
disprove them
by the sort of automated theorem
improving systems
that are trained over the full uh fly
spec
corpus so so in
we we cannot do too much like the
theorem players are
not terribly strong yet uh
but sometimes this can really work in
the sense that
we manage to prove or disprove a
particular
parts of of the
coming out of the basically
system that translates the informal to
to the formal statement
but what also happens quite often is
that
the the system can
uh create an undid unintended form of
parse
that is actually provable so so then
you can sort of use this system for some
sort of conjecturing
when you take let's say a formal
statement then you informalize it by
forgetting about the formal parts of the
expression
and then you formalize it back and and
that gives you
sort of many disambiguations
that sometimes can for example be more
general than what you intended so so
this way we for example formalized
a statement uh stated for
square matrices to rectangular matrices
and it turned out that we we could prove
it automatically
and the fact actually wasn't in the
whole light library or the flight spec
library so so that way
you can sort of augment the your
corporates your
textbook uh let me
say a bit about this premise selection
so that's this task of
choosing many uh
from from a really big purpose only only
if you are all on premises
and i'll go a bit fast now and
this this is really used today
for assisting the um
the users of the interactive crm so so
it results in system called
hammers and it's especially popularized
in isabel in a system called slogan
and what you can see down here are the
success rates of these systems so so
these systems
take a conjecture written in the
language of some interactive theorem
theory
translate it to automated theorem
proving uh let's say formalism
uh apply the premise selection so so
they
choose a small number of the most
relevant
facts from from the big corpus and
if if then the automated theorem preview
gets the proof they sort of translate
the two back
into the interactive improving formulas
and and these systems have become really
very useful so some five years ago we
could do like 40 to 45 percent
of the several big
corporate uh these days on medjay we can
do something like 60 and 60 percent
fully automatically so so it really
shows you how
how much the sort of machine learning
methods
help like like the main difference
between these 40 and the 60 person
is basically putting machine learning
into
into the automated interior empirics and
the uh
selection systems i'll
show you yeah this is one example
of a proof a complicated long proof like
this
uh face of polyhedron being a polyhedron
written in whole light and what
what the methods can do is that they
quite often find
an alternative to so so the trained
machine learner
sees the 20 000 proofs in
in this big library and quite often it
sort of sees wider
than the mathematician who is
formalizing the truth by some sort of
standard procedure
and it can see lemons that the
mathematician
didn't realize are already there and
that sort of give him much shorter
proof basically so so this is one
example where
where the long proof written by the
mathematician has been
reduced to an alternative proof which is
which is much shorter
uh i i think i might
skip the internal guidance
so so basically the internal guidance
can be done
for various automated fear improvers
like
one thing that we did early was to take
a simple
three very called connection through a
or tableau qriver called clean cop
and and it sort of does the proofs in
this sort of
pablo way where you are closing each
branch by having opposite literals on it
and uh what you can do is basically
something like the
alphago alpha zero for chess playing so
so you
guide the application of the rules to
to to this sort of proof construction by
some learning from from the previous
proofs like which rules were applied to
which partial
partial proof and the this
this is actually leading to a
quite a good improvement so if you
if you iterate it several times
you start from something that is
relatively weak for for example this
and by some sort of five eight
iterations
you get to to something that is some 40
percent
stronger than the sort of human
heuristic
written um
you you can i'll skip this you you can
also do this for for the sort of
complicated state of the art here in
previous like this enigmaio's already
mentioning
so so here i'm showing that in in some
sort of
six iterations of the learning and
proving
you can get from some fifteen thousand
crews to something like fifty
twenty five thousand proof so in a sort
of controlled scenario with 10 seconds
cpu limit it gives you something like 70
percent improvement
but by doing by doing a lot of the
machine learning on on the previous
previous proves uh so so that's that's
really
unexpectedly looks like when we when we
go this it really surprised us like how
how far it it it got us
and he he respond to for example the
master fix point theorem that he can now
do completely automatically
uh i should be wrapping up and i think i
already
mentioned this symbolic guidance of um
sort of low-level automated theorem
previous done by people
so this is just a teaser you should be
watching mike opinion and both way of
announcing announcing a big breakthrough
in very very chris uh nine and tens
uh i will probably skip this because i'm
out of time so this is the tactical
system by
tibor gautier so the mid-level guidance
of the whole follower system and and
that that has been again like researched
quite a lot recently
uh i'll also skip this
but i will show you yeah so so recently
there are these systems
that for example do program synthesis
and and you can use them
equally for generating programs
so so here's one program generated by a
transformer by
gpd2 which uh which actually
is fake so it's it's not a real proof
like if you
sort of understand the terminology you
would see that
some of these steps are like totally
semantically incorrect
but the interesting stuff is that the
sort of transformer style machine
learner
can really perfectly learn the syntax
and and also the sort of natural
reduction rules here so
so the proof actually type checks and
like these sort of conjecturing systems
actually can
sometimes today produce new conjectures
that we can automatically verify
and here is an example where it for
example generalize
unknown theorem in the music library
from finite groups to
to non-finite like arbitrary groups
and then we needed to ask mathematicians
because we are stupid
whether it's through all false because
we couldn't prove it automatically and
they confirmed that
this is actually provable so so it's
it's good fun to play
with with these sort of linguistic
technologies for
generating producers okay
maybe the last funny thing to show you
is this autoformalization so
so we we took about one million
examples of latex and formal
statements and train neural
machine translation on them like
sequence of sequence
and then we played with it and here you
can see the results
so you you start training
and initially the the 1000 snapshot is
really bad so so it tries to
translate this latex into this correct
statement
but it generates like a total garbage
initially
but as you train over and over on these
one million examples
the the machine translator becomes
better and better
and by snapshot 7000 it basically
produces
what is the correct uh statement
so so so that's sort of one teaser for
doing the autoformalization work for
training machine translation tools
to to take the huge amount of informal
written mathematical textbooks and
trying to turn them
into this formally parsable
formal formal language languages that we
can actually verify
so that's it here are some
acknowledgments references
and my advertisement for the artificial
intelligence and theorem brewing
conference which is happening
probably in a hybrid mode this year in
oslo
thanks for your attention
okay so thank you josef for
for the uh comprehensive talk
so um i'm just checking if there are any
questions so
well one the first one is is fairly
technical on slide six
why is there a uh red line in the proof
uh so you have this a squared is even
and why is that red
yeah so sorry about that this is just an
artifact of
fragrance vidic outlining uh
aligning the two two uh
statements in the informal and
and the formal uh version of
the proof okay so there's no
actual uh consequence of that
yeah yeah okay um
there's another question how long it
will it take for a computer to
win a fields medal
[Laughter]
oh so
i i would say so so maybe
what i can show you is a bit of these
proofs that we are
we are getting today uh so
so what we are getting is not really
something
that would be beating mathematicians so
i don't know what i got yesterday
uh was something like this for example
so so we have like a 400 long proof
in 26 seconds about
um about an equivalent characterization
of uh primality
in in a similar test so so i would say
if you if you have never studied this if
you are some
initial student of algebra you that
there is no way how
i will give you 260 axioms
and you will in 23 seconds produce a
proof life like this
so so on one hand like what what we are
now having is is in some sense
already fairly good uh but it's
not so good in doing
sort of the high level stuff that the
mathematicians are doing
and that i i would say
that there is there is a bunch of
exceptions like bonus
for example this work that michael
kenyon and bob beref are doing
on the aim conjecture where like i just
said
like they just got a big breakthrough
and they can produce proofs that have
100 000
inferences and no human can
compete well maybe humans can use
other methods and actually michael is
sort of combining the
theorem period with this sort of high
level understanding of the topic
uh but in in some sense i would say
if if there were a fields model for um
for for doing quasi group and loop
theory
then through a nine in combination with
michael kenyon and goldberg
would be strong candidates these days so
in some sense this also depends like on
on what the mathematical community uh
considers to be worth
of the fields metal uh i i don't know
that
uh what what is sort of the
interesting thing that that we are
definitely not reaching yet
is um do doing
uh doing this sort of more high level
planning
conjecturing theory exploration and
i would say the the sort of
good thing is that if you if you look
for example on alphago or
alpha zero you you can also see some
sort of progression there
that initially the system is sort of
quite low level
but then it sort of automatically takes
off
just by this combination of learning and
doing search
and learning from the successes and it
can
in the end become pretty good and doing
some high level patterns and very
sophisticated
games so it's it's unclear
at the moment whether something similar
might not happen with our approach like
basically going
from this very syntactic uh level where
we have
the sort of formal proof feedback
teaching us
to to go to more and more
high-level thinking and patterns uh
if if you want some sort of definitive
answer for me
then the the the standard deadline that
ai researchers are putting on everything
is 20 years
but i i don't know like i i would
probably go more like 50 years
okay so i think we we just ran out of
time
so thank you josef for the talk thank
you for
all the questions and
well i hope to see you all in a person
at some point
okay thanks a lot michael thanks for the
opportunity
and have fun with the rest of the
conference
bye bye
you